so at the age of 16 while most of my
friends were off being camp counselors
and whatnot
i was working on the floor of the new
york mercantile exchange
[Music]
nicole prior thank you so much for
joining me on 20 minute leaders
thank you it's an honor to be here so
great to have you i'm i'm really excited
to to do the show with you
and i'm i'm especially excited to hear
about your journey you know
how you got into vc what does this mean
to you and there are quite
a few stories that i'm especially
excited to hear about but let's just get
started
nicole tell me who you are and and why
are you in venture capital
yeah so i'm nicole i grew up
in london maryland and new york and
growing up in new york you start growing
up
really fast so at the age of 16 while
most of my friends were off being camp
counselors and whatnot
i was working on the floor of the new
york mercantile exchange the commodities
floor working for
natural gas and oil traders and that
really propelled my career
into the world of investments so i went
from there to a hedge fund that was also
trading oil and gas options then when i
went to
university why why at 16 are you doing
this who at 16 goes
and and does this i realized that
uh you know you have to give it your all
and if you really want to get ahead in
life
you need to put your best foot forward
so it was the beginning of experiential
learning this whole concept of
learning outside the classroom and i
wanted to build my
resume and position myself well
career-wise so i was thinking already
about
college and post-college and i've
figured all right i've done the camp
thing now it's time to move on
wow okay so you're doing all these sorts
of internships what else have you done
up leading up to college and through
college
and not not much else i was quite boring
i volunteered a lot in new york i was um
i was pretty active
as a high school student at the time
israel was actually
in a tough spot with the second intifada
so i was pretty active going to
protests and demonstrations and things
like that
yes it was a busy time i started the
zionist action committee in high school
um and then i i went up to boston in
for university and i continued on um
doing interesting things i studied
abroad at hebrew u
when i was when i was 19 my junior year
and that's where i actually met my
husband by the way
so i fell in love with the age of 19 and
set me up for the rest of my life but i
came back to
i came back to university i came back to
boston in 2007 2008
and i had basically like
been exposed to this whole startup tech
ecosystem in israel
which was really nascent in the us
especially on the east coast
it wasn't really the thing it is today
but i was really interested in learning
more about it so
i discovered lo and behold that boston
is a mecca for
vc so i just shot off like something
like 24 cold emails to all the vcs in
boston i said
hey i'm a student i want to work for you
i want to get experience i'm happy to
volunteer my time
two got back to me once said we'd love
to have you but we literally don't have
the space
and the other said you know what we're
actually going through a rebranding
and we would love to have a college
student on board to help us through that
so that was flybridge capital partners
um took a chance on me and it was a
great experience
so
yeah i mean you know then you're looking
at it and you're saying okay
not many college students haven't have
an opportunity to work for vc at that at
that point
and you could look at it in the in the
sense of yeah i got a position but but
then the backstory of there were for 20
23 other cold emails that either went
unanswered or were rejected
it puts things in perspective on how
much you have to sometimes you know
and just shoot for the moon and and
hopefully something comes up
so talk to me a little bit about about
your experience in that vc and
what were you doing there so it was
great i set up
their social media pages like i created
their
linkedin page they were undergoing a
rebranding so i was helping with a lot
of marketing efforts
i sat in on pitch meetings with
brilliant entrepreneurs
and i even did some due diligence um
there was a
interesting company that came through
two former executives from
scott toilet paper had an idea for a
fertilizer company so i rented a car
the only car they had on lot was this
like red dodge charger that looked like
a sports car
but it's also used as an undercover
police car
and i drove that down to new york and i
visited all these home and gardening
shops places like home depot
and i was inspecting all the different
fertilizers and speaking to sales people
and customers about their fertilizer
options
so that was that was really really fun
and it set me up well to do
vc post university so okay so you're
finishing university and you decide you
you want to continue doing the vc
life what and so what happens next
yeah so actually i graduated in 2008 i
don't know if you know
what was going on in 2008 but it was not
a good time to graduate university much
like today it's not
a good time to graduate college in 2020.
um so i got a job at exxonmobil because
while the markets were down
oil was sky high it was a hundred forty
dollars a barrel so
things were moving there yeah the free
barrels we had the other day
yeah yeah crazy how fast things change
and by the way that's why so many energy
oil and gas traders
blow up they just you can have a good
year and then you can have value and be
totally right
yeah yeah so i went to work for xl
mobile in a management training program
for two years
and from there i moved to israel and
rejoined the investment
world wow okay so so investment why
you know at the end of the day obviously
i mean it's fun it's luxurious
you get to meet a lot of entrepreneurs
but but why choose the investment route
and you know i get to experience some of
this
in in some of this vc world here in the
early stage fungi ventures and
and it's so so exciting but but i but i
can see both sides to it so why are you
so attracted to this world
you know i'm gonna tell you half joking
half serious
i'm in love with babies okay since
since i was a young girl i was obsessed
with babies there's something that's so
cute about them
and i've always been a huge fan once
they're one
not so interesting i let my husband take
care of them
giving me them for the first year and
then they're all yours um
so startups for me are like babies
they're honestly like babies my youngest
now is one
so she's in that not cute category and
i heard i heard the terrible twos that
count i didn't hear about the
i i thought you have two cute ears
not not in my book um
but but when you're helping companies
from their very earliest stages from
their inception
grow you pick them up when they cry you
show them the way
you hold their hands you give advice you
know you open doors for them literally
and and figuratively it's very similar
to helping nurture
a small baby so i love cute babies i
love exciting startups and
it really gets me going waking up every
morning and thinking about
how can we help grow this business today
or who is the next exciting
entrepreneur or company to come out of
israel
how many deals would you see you've been
a part of over the years
and over your experiences how many
entrepreneurs have you had a chance to
deal with
so i have been working in the investment
field for
over 10 years now um and i've seen a lot
of different stages
late stage public public equities
pre-ipo growth companies early stage
and at ibex we also we invest across all
those stages
over the years we invested in 23 israeli
companies
since since 2012 we've had seven exits
so
really stellar returns wow and we're
actually doubling down on
israel and just yesterday we closed our
second
um closed our second israel fund wow
thank you thank you we're really excited
to double down
that's amazing oh yeah so you're a vice
president at ibex investors
what what is this group and what is sort
of the you know the thesis that you guys
go with
so believe it or not back in 2011 the
founder
of of ibex this guy from denver
reads a startup nation book gets on a
plane comes to israel
does a little trip here gets back to
denver and says
wow we've got to do something in israel
the innovation there is out of control
so they started with a really small fund
today it's
multiples of that and they just started
investing uh
you know in public and private israeli
companies
and we have the name ibex a lot of
people
don't know what ibex are yeah especially
israelis which is ironic
um but if you're familiar with uh yael
the the animal yes
yes yes the animal the animal down south
around meets pheromone and that is able
to climb almost 90 degree angles like to
rid
something amazing on the on the hills
there you go so most israelis don't know
that they're like what's ibex then we
say
yell and they're like oh okay okay cool
so so why but what is it about the
animal that's exciting and that reminds
of
of you know the entrepreneurial spirit
perhaps
the founder of ibex likes to joke that
we didn't name
our fund ibex because it's an exotic
elegant
animal who's able to scale difficult
terrain
we named it ibex because it was the
first name of
of um freddie mercury's band
joking joking joking jokes aside
okay amazing okay so and how many people
are how many people are part of this
group
we're 21 people with offices in denver
new york and tel aviv
incredible okay and so so you meet so is
your position in israel do you just
meet all sorts of interesting startups
from all sorts of stages and then bring
it back to the group and decide
together whether to invest or not or or
how does it how does a community
actually work
yeah that's basically it so um
i meet lots of companies nowadays it's
mainly on zoom and that's
that's cool um but we can move really
fast we meet companies we
conduct some due diligence we do have an
investment committee where we decide if
this is a go or no go
with the last investment we made we met
the company just before covet broke out
or as
covert was breaking out in the world and
we did the deal
you know on lockdown so we we moved very
fast
from the first meeting till the term
sheet it was 10 days
so despite the the miles between myself
and my partners
in denver uh we we moved pretty quickly
no i think it's actually it's
interesting and quite a few people have
been
telling me that a lot of these things
have been accelerated
due to covet because now if people were
waiting for an
or waiting for a physical meeting in the
office a lot of the times they
they said okay well now there's we don't
have to wait next week until we're all
in the same location
we can just do it tonight over zoom and
get things rolling so i've actually been
hearing this quite a lot
but you know i'd love to get your
perspective so you've you've been
observing the israeli ecosystem for the
past 10 years i'm assuming right
and i'd love to get sort of your insight
into
what have you what have you observed
about the israeli ecosystem perhaps
you know in comparison to other
ecosystems and and i mean i'm asking for
myself because i i don't know enough yet
and
and it's fascinating to me
yeah it's a really good question i i did
not spend time in silicon valley but
what i can observe
from israel is that the ecosystem here
is incredibly collaborative
everyone really lends a helping hand to
everybody else so you don't have those
competitive
stealthy you know maneuvers where people
are trying to
to outbid or you know out maneuver
someone else
so it's very collaborative very open
forum for discussion with other funds we
share
deal flow we share ideas um
founders are always willing to help help
younger founders and mentor them
what what is it about why why why does
the israeli ecosystem
have this collaborative nature i mean
obviously
i love israelis i'm israeli myself and
and you know
and it in shows on the street and on the
beach but but i would imagine that when
it comes to
you know venture capital to
entrepreneurship i mean
there's only so many good deals out
there and there's a lot of
vcs who are looking for them
it's david and goliath we're a country
the size of new jersey that's
mainly made up of sand trying to break
into the big old
united states of america where there's
tons of capital flowing
tons of tons of you know interesting
people and startups that are coming out
and we need to
literally cross mountains and oceans to
get there
so whatever we can do to help each other
succeed like
someone else's success is my success and
likewise
so i think i think we're up against a
great challenge and we need every
everybody's participation and
cooperation to to surmount that
and is your decision to to focus
primarily your efforts on the israeli
ecosystem is that
out of any you know professional
strategy or is
or is that mainly your love for the
country and the fact that you made
aliyah for that
it's a mixture of both so we have lps we
have a fiduciary duty we return capital
to our investors israel is a great place
to deploy capital and to be able to
to get those returns those venture style
returns
um that we're looking for personally and
professionally
it also obviously strikes a chord in my
heart to be a part of it and
right to help that and i mean you i mean
so given that you you've been as
practically a zionist since high school
and leading these efforts i mean it
definitely shows talk to me a little bit
about you know some of the things that
you've observed with
with young entrepreneurs versus maybe
serial entrepreneurs
and that's always a fascinating topic
for me what what does it mean to
you know a lot of people give so much
credit to serial entrepreneurs because
they've gone through different things
what what have you been observing and
what type of entrepreneur are you most
excited to work with
so maybe this is a bit unconventional
but
serial entrepreneurs they're great and
yes they have the experience they've
been through the whole cycle they know
the ups and downs and when they come up
to that to do it again
it says a certain thing about that
person that
they know how tough and grueling it is
and they're willing to do it again and
that's phenomenal
but when we look for invest when we look
for founders to back
we're actually looking for the ones who
don't have that experience
who have a chip on their shoulder who
feel like they have something to prove
and are determined to make it big
wow so you're actually on some way
preferring a first-time entrepreneur
rather than a cereal obviously every
every deal on its own but but
overall you're more excited about these
first-time entrepreneurs
yeah i've never heard that before
amazing okay so and and you know but but
with the chip on the shoulder comes the
you know the the the lack of facing the
adversities and the lack of experience
and so you are foregoing all that
experience for the you know the passion
the motivation
and that you know initial excitement
yeah that's true so it means there is a
little bit more hand-holding
and we went from our mistakes we learned
from our mistakes but
we're prepared to roll our sleeves up
and help them out and
um i think that they also have a lot to
teach us so
we're happy to give them the chance
we're not stubborn about
you know second timers right so i mean
and also this idea of being an active
investor versus a passive investor and
sometimes holding hands and being there
for them
how much of that you know meeting
alignment of expectations is there
before you go into a collaboration with
an entrepreneur
or how much understanding is there
between the two parties on
how much or how intensive this
relationship is going to be
because it can go always right totally
totally and you never know until you
jump in it's a massive leap of faith
massive and that's why so much of it
comes down to the team and the chemistry
between the investor
and the founders because you're
literally spending
you know day in and day out with each
other for
five ten maybe fifteen years even so
all those expectations should come up at
the in the beginning with the
understanding that things can change and
things will change
so gotta just hope for the best
and is that something that you can
reasonably aim to really understand
within a matter of 10 days due diligence
i mean that's
that's very fast for the responsibility
of
of of aligning expectations and and
realizing if this is going to be a good
relationship
yeah well 10 days actually sounds like a
lot when when you think about it
you developed like an intuition and it
got instinct within the first
10 minutes of meeting someone so you
know pretty much
from the outset whether this is
something that could potentially work or
not so compare that's the next 10 days
of due diligence
it's the 80 20 rule so i yeah sure i
could spend three months
uh you know speaking to every person
who's ever encountered the founders but
is that really going to make it
you know a difference in terms of our
decision probably not
right and i think i think one thing that
i've been observing is that more and
more funds are taking
ownership over this fast and this quick
decision making i nfx famously did that
over coved
and fusion labs in la also three weeks
uh
three weeks until a deal i think ten
days is extraordinary but but it sounds
like
also this is a greater incentive now for
entrepreneurs as well to
to trust the to trust the vc and
do is do you think that is because there
is more
there are more vcs now looking for the
great talent which is scarce
and it needs to be more attractive or is
that really because the vc wants to be
more efficient
and and see more deals throughout the
year is it the chicken or the egg
that's i don't know if we'll ever answer
that question
sufficiently um definitely you're right
that
there's more and more companies today
not necessarily all of them
are venture appropriate there's this
misconception i think that if you want
to start a company that you need to go
out and take venture and i feel very
strongly that
venture capital is not the model for
most businesses out there
so there's alternatives and
entrepreneurs need to keep that in mind
that
venture capital is not is not
the mold you know for everyone and for
every type of business so
they shouldn't really necessarily spend
a lot of time chasing venture
capitalists if it's not appropriate for
them and they can speak to a couple
people and and verify that pretty
quickly i think
um and depending on the vc yeah
efficiency is key we're looking to do
three to four investments a year
so we obviously have uh you know there's
a lot of deal flow in the in the
pipeline
and when we meet the ones who we want to
work with
we can move very quickly right no i
think that then
it's it's fascinating to me this work
that you can you you know you spend so
much time
learning meeting so many people at the
end it comes down to are these few key
investments that you make on a yearly
basis
and and you know you when you say four
investments here it doesn't necessarily
sound like a lot but when you put it in
the context of
you know seeing hundreds of companies
and and going through that
it's going through that filter which has
to be really really precise because at
the end
this is the you know fiduciary
responsibility you have towards your
other investors
i think it's just an incredible journey
nicole right before we leave i have to
ask you the most important question
three words that describe you
oh my god wow
the first things that come to mind this
is not a
huge commitment all right i always live
by the mantra
you never know you never know
explain that to me um so many people are
afraid to take a leap
afraid to make a change unsure of what's
to come
and i say hey you really never know
what's
what's going to be this could turn out
to be the best decision of your life or
you think that you're going to do
x but it's going to turn out to be y so
nothing is
certain and just listen to the new york
lottery that was their motto you never
know
i think it's awesome and i think it's
probably one of the best
mindsets you can go in to the industry
that we're living in
because you just never know and and
every day i'm surprised by something new
that's happening
and i think that's just what makes it so
exciting it's the unpredictability
and it's the fact that literally
anything is possible and and you never
know
nicole todd thank you very very much and
thank you for your time thank you for
your generosity and have
a fantastic day thank you it was a
pleasure speaking with you
take care bye bye